[Musik]
ich habe alles recht eigentlich habt ihr
zeit um weihnachten gibt warum sparen
die kunden bekommen beim ein video
ich bin in einer küche und an ich kann
das ja erst mal nichts gutes bedeutet
meine
ja es aber freunde und ich hab mich
leute weil wir als ganz besonderes
überlegt gleich ob die letzten beiden
male möglichkeiten gebraten und wenn
jetzt noch auf die geniale idee gekommen
nimmt keine möglichkeiten nimm einfach
mal alltagsgegenstände wie zum beispiel
zahnpasta duschgel charakter oder auch
duschen jahre äußeren deswegen raten wir
heute alltagsgegenstände aber erstmal
vorweg sagen möchte macht es auch keinen
falls verordnet passive die nur der
unterhaltung und geht jetzt nicht gegen
die im supermarkt und nicht die fahne
polo hofer und grafik
ich glaube da in ihm aber ein bisschen
böse danach ihr könnt natürlich
versuchen ist mir egal aber ich werde
hier ansicht und das haus ja irgendwann
später heiratet folgendes passiert es
ist eine stunde vorbei ist muss diese
zeitplanung tauschen
der mit zwei fallen weil das hier keine
induktion fahrer rabatt und dass ihr
einher
er funktioniert wohl nur mit induktion
fallen aber ich werde mich einlagern
bestelle ich meinte tottenham-trainer
leben in moskau wieder volk hat auch
viel stein warten dass man nach oben da
wenngleich von merkwürdigkeiten warten
als ehrgeizig wie die ganzen produkte
ich habe mir gedacht ich auch mal für
die medien ein wirklich erstmal gucken
hat mit dem passiert dann haben wir
zuletzt auch wieder alltäglich danach
wie zahnpasta benutzen auch als ich
jetzt nicht so alltäglich aber niemals
schon und wir haben jetzt du stand also
schaffen
das ist wichtig dass du kein geld
verkaufen abonnenten sich nochmal mit
kohle hafen da passiert sowas coole sich
ab märz in den letzten schluck aus
meiner letzten monaten aufgebahrt
und er ätzte der bayern ich habe mega
wieder so aufgeregt
es wird auf jeden fall ich würde sagen
wir lassen heute alter das geht mir zu
langsam
leute ohne spaß wir machen einfach nicht
was in solln passiert glaube ich nicht
viel
alle reifen leute mache doch kein
vergleich zu verstehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kleine partner
danke
also leute ohne spaß hatten niemals auf
die idee ein kaugummi auch die einzige
aber es nicht mehr konnten würden unter
hat hier stinkt es mir ja richtig so
richtig schade irgendwie so okay leute
und wenn sie erst mal zehn minuten
komplett durch das sind immer noch
brennt ein loch in den augen und
deswegen den weg einfach schaffen damit
sie wieder glücklich bin ich richtig
gespannt und shampoo habe ich so doch in
der halle zwei flaschen hätte solch eine
spaß macht es besser ihn niemand einfach
als nach bitte einfach nicht
[Musik]
nicht ein spiel was passiert damit
ich bin jetzt mehr gespart dass das geld
auch bekannt als mensch passierte klagen
ich hab' alles macht ihn mit einem
weihnachtsfest aufschrift warum sparte
cool wie das wurde gestern gekauft
später dann in behandlung wenn das
passiert dann gleich noch über kein
talent steht fest die an rhein und
einbrüchen bei schlecker und wieder als
wenn man in der politik werden
[Musik]
hey leute ich glaube da passiert nicht
mehr die nächste runde
und zwar an alle müssen wir leider die
realität gewordenen lippenstift zerstöre
aber nach dem was mit einem passiert
eltern für
[Musik]
woanders trittin als du gedacht dass das
so schnell klein
so weist die letzte wir machen weiter
mit dem letzten punkt hier bin ich
gespannt ich weiter bin ich voll
reinhauen vielleicht mal gehen aber
weniger rasch passiert wenn man fast
gedreht ich habe keine ahnung ich wollte
auch ein jahr zu gehen aber wenn man
youtube kann man auch ganz komische
ideen von renten oder mac wird das
trocknen im cockpit schleifer
fachkundigen raum
in der zwischenzeit seien werte firma
ein neues weltweit gibt es wieder
geschafft
heute so eingestanden hatte
[Musik]
was sogar von der farbe hatten beim
bully vor nur leute erst mal was ihr
versagen uns mit cola da kam ich will
raus bringt jetzt gelassen auf jeden
fall sonnenblende zwischen am anfang
gesagt mach das bitte auf keinen fall zu
ordnen wie gesagt das ist einfach nur
unterhaltung so mainformat tätigkeit
paten blabla irgendwas anderes
partnersuche ich mein tor bekommt man
sonst zu sehen wie es aussieht wenn es
so krass erhitzt wird ich bin irgendwie
witzig es noch mehr spaß dieses video zu
drehen und ich hoffe es hat euch auch
gefallen deswegen hat danach um endlich
gefallen hat wenn ihr bock habt auf
süßigkeiten braten teil 3 oder etwas
anderem eine kommentar schreiben macht
man so vielleicht mal machen kann in
zukunft ich freue mich drauf
und ja gerne auch hierbei weit
vorbeischauen meinem eigenen klamotten
label ganz oben wieder beschreibung
verlinkt auch viele mädels und jungs
dabei ist ein geradezu mädels und jungs
außer aldo kropf haupt und sowas mehr
will ich dazu gar nicht sagen
wir sehen uns haut rein